hi this is International master David
proofs for chest comm and today you are
going to learn the most fundamental of
chess tactics something called double
attack and double attack is fundamental
because in some sense most winning
tactical operations and chess games are
double attacks think about it this way
if I make one threat at a time you
should usually be able to discern what
I'm trying to do and then defend against
it but if I make two attacks at once or
let's say three attacks at once which is
harder but a triple threat of some kind
it becomes increasingly unlikely that
you have a move that actually deals with
both threats right anyway let's not get
ahead of ourselves let's define the
double attack let's make sure that you
know what it is so see on my position
here in this position if white plays the
move e5 that is a double attack there's
a threat to take the pawn or to take the
knight now this isn't a winning double
attack but it is a double attack it's
not a double attack that wins because
you know the threat to trade pawns isn't
really a threat that the black cares
about but this is an example of a move
that attacks two things and that's
classic for a double attack now let me
quickly show you what is not a double
attack this famous
bad opening white threatens f7 with two
pieces right which would be a form of
checkmate scholars made this is not a
double attack this is two pieces
attacking one thing but there's a single
threat so this is not a double attack
this is a coordination of the pieces
coordinating pieces is great but it's
not necessarily a double attack there's
one threat and black stops it easily by
chasing the Queen back blocking her
attack okay so now let us see the double
attack in action I'm going to show you
two quick games so you'll see how the
double attack can decide a chess game
this is a variation basically the
symmetrical English opening and here
black is trying to
back in the center you see after trading
one of white center pawns black
aggressively pushes both his pawns into
the center white trades one off and
black takes back here now in this
position white can set up a winning
double attack that will basically end
the game in White's favor here on move
seven you can pause the video if you
want to try and guess any of these
things yourself but I'm going to go
ahead because I don't have much time and
show you Queen tags knight on d5 taking
a knight for free if black captures
White's Queen then Knight c7 this is not
just a double attack but a triple attack
and after the King moves and white tapes
back White has an X from knight in the
end game and should win if they play
well so that was a double attack which
White's setup with the Queen sacrifice
why not use flashy examples right if you
can alright now here is another game
which was decided even faster by a
series of double attacks similar opening
this is a game that I've actually played
myself I so white has recaptured in the
center with the knight they've developed
their pieces but they don't really have
a pawn presence in the center so black
now wins the game with two double
attacks in a row first the pawn comes
here and this is a very very classic
double attack upon just stepping
somewhere where it attacks two pieces
clear double attack and you see why it's
hard to avoid both threats you know if
if you move the knight away your bishop
can still be captured same if you move
your bishop away so there are limited
resources for dealing with double
attacks one of them is to capture the
attacking piece the other is to move one
of your pieces where it makes a really
big threat for example if this bishop
could come here and this were a big
threat then that might save the two
white pieces from the double attack
because if black takes white knight
white can take the pawn on g7 but here
the bishop doesn't really have any good
threat to go make because this knight is
defended okay
so the only way here for white try and
pulling the game is to capture the pawn
with the bishop now black makes a second
double attack Queen a5 check attacks the
King and attacks the bishop and white
could defend this if his knight weren't
in the way on d4 and he could play his
Bishop to c3 that would block the check
on the King and save the bishop but here
he can't the best way I can do is to
block the check on his King and black
captures the bishop and black should go
on to win the game pretty easily so you
see here a double attack twice in a row
this is why a lot of chess tactics are
built on the double attack it's the most
important chess tactic to no one into
the other two threats at a time hard to
answer and grandmaster URI Auber Bach
who is great soviet grandmaster said
that all chess tactics are based on the
double attack it's not quite true but
most of them are the vast majority 90 95
% of chess tactics are a series of
multiple threats I hope you enjoyed this
video and I'll see you around on chess
calm